il remportait sa deuxième Coupe de
France de boxe le 29 avril dernier
désormais c'est la ceinture continentale
Ibo qu'il vise à l'incendu le boxeur
professionnel de l'US Joué-lès-Tours
affrontera le tenant du titre à Toulouse
le 24 juin prochain une manière pour lui
de relancer sa carrière romain Delville
a rencontré lors d'une de ses séances
d'entraînement au Palais des Sports
Marcel Cerdan
supérieure deux fois vainqueur de la
Coupe de France chez les super légers et
les léger le boxeur de Joué-lès-Tours
s'attaque à une ceinture continentale
Ibo face aux tenant du titre le
Toulousain Anthony rivière aujourd'hui
on a changé tout on a changé parce que
il paraît que tout le monde a su comment
je bosse aujourd'hui et on veut amener
de
amener boxer plus vite et plus fort et
puissance et là on travaille tout ça
parce que je dis il nous attendent une
autre façon mais on va aller surprendre
que Alain sengué ne plus parler il a
changé et son style de boxe aussi a
changé sous l'impulsion de son coach job
merci Alain sanguin est moins attentiste
ce doit d'être plus combatif et aller de
l'avant sur le terrain de son adversaire
sanguin doit penser en conquérant c'est
c'est un très grand technicien c'est un
garçon qui s'adapte très très vite à
l'adversaire et maintenant ce que je lui
demande vraiment vraiment de m'écouter
au moment qu'il est dans le ring le
combat entre deux à deux on pourra
battre un mec et tout seul c'est un peu
plus compliqué une nouvelle étape un
nouveau palier s'offre à Alain sanguin à
lui de saisir sa chance pour viser plus
haut